they supplied to you these two fats that
should be in PR about the angle fear
that if you put it into the first
equation it's true
and also that you know this restriction
about a fence on the right hand side and
then they ask you to find this
expression tan of theta minus hundred
eighty degrees and it pulls them quite a
lot of knowledge from different sources
wife and challenging question let's
start by having a look at this okay now
most people's instinct when they see
this is pain that's an equation I'll
solve this range right and you can solve
this equation that's great
it just is not the question that's all
right and they also ask you for exact
now you which and you will see shortly
it's a bit of a problem if you just go
through your stock standard I'll take
this thing and our soul watch if three
coz theta plus two equals zero is your
starting point and your intent is to
solve we're going to need to make that
true function the subject so what shall
I do to our time I'm going to track two
from both sides which gives me this and
then I'm going to divide both sides by
three now this point you should
recognize this will not hand you back an
exact value not at least without quite a
little bit of legwork okay you're going
to get some awkward decimal place
rubbish out of this way you took this
into your calculator right so with
regard to this question we're kind of a
little bit stuck there goodness just
solving this is not actually the way to
go about this you can actually pour with
this moment pour TR and think about how
relations do the rest of the question I
want to find out can't be amount 180
degrees
I don't need to know exactly what figure
is I just need to know enough about it
for instance this thing here if you want
to think that to this even though it's
awesome let's talk about it in here you
have information about which of these
quadrants
Caesar must be in
I'm a big Cosita equals negative 2/3 so
therefore you can take some the quadrant
of the road which ones are possible
wanted foreigner group because in each
of those causes positive okay and you
now know information that excludes that
so now you're over here and it reminds
you of weight I have other piece of
information that was supplied to me in
the question now I know it's not just
second or third if care video is
positive then I can only be with them
okay so now I know I have this third
quadrant angle I suppose I would say
between 180 degrees and 270 degrees
that's likely is going to be okay now I
can use that information to say oh okay
and Peter - Anjali degrees I can get to
Ted beta from this amount of dimension
this is kind of all I need right if I
redraw my quadrants I going without so
much mess on it cos theta equals -2 and
3 where's my triangle going to go it's
something like this right where are they
- two in the three or the two of the -
tree which ones which is better right
causes which ratio on a rating will
travel it's adjacent on hypotenuse yes
so the way I would probably label this
is that's negative 2 it's gone to the
left and here is 3 there's my hypotenuse
adjacent or - so far so good now I can
use this information to get the missing
side let's not worry too much about the
working what is the missing side that's
squared is 9 that square is 4 so over
here you're going to have the square
root of 5 right I will point out by the
way um even though a bit noise comes on
a diagram on a triangle rather Sokol
length this is going down right so this
root 5 is really actually
negative root 5 which is why now looking
in this triangle right what can be done
what ratio is it it's opposite on
adjacent is it not so that's actually to
be careful with the Sun is actually
negative root 5 on negative 2 which is
why in the third quadrant 10 is positive
which is easy to cancel ok so there can
be a negative sorry positive root 5 on 2
that's nice but it's not what the
question was asking for so how I get
from this knowledge what's my bridge to
get to this what will I do I can think
of least 2 a 0 I can I can just put this
into the calculator and find out a value
for theta I should point out that I
could have done that before right and
that's like either didn't go down that
part because I wanted an exact value
I've got certainty so I know I'm going
to end up with a bit of mess out the
other end there are two ways you can go
about this we're doing graphing this
morally right because you're graphing
that delete one of the waves what does
the graph of 10 look like I need to do
more
here's 10 right like all the
trigonometric functions one of the most
important things about it is that it is
periodic it repeats how often does it
repeats every 180 degrees every 180
means you get the same thing right so as
an example here is 45 degrees right it's
halfway to that asymptote at 90 degrees
what 10 or 45 it's 1 right that means
that 10 to 45 plus 180 my girlfriend
Renee degrees forward like this right
that's underneath each word what angular
- by the way this point - 25
so what's 10 - 25
just look at the it's 1
it's not just like 1045 ones 1 you can
go forward 180 degrees as many times as
you like you can go forward again
- to 405 degrees and then you go forward
again to 585 degrees and every time
you're still going to get one right well
if you can get for 180 degrees
repeatedly instead - reason you should
be able to go back to Geneva
and you'll get the same thing which is
in fact it did equal to tan theta do you
see that right because I'm I'm hijacking
the periodicity of kid right if it has a
copy every 180 degrees you guys forward
underneath or backward 180 you're going
to get exactly the same thing so this is
root five one two
you can you can actually just evaluate
if you want okay however we're looking
either show what's going on so that's
why I'm not going to a pivot tango as
much of a sort of camera it's on a way
you could do this it's a bit of a long
way around
but it's also possible if you're you ad
graphing what else could you do easy to
do
come on how to look at it yeah I can use
the expansion that's right as an
extension what it student I know the
expansion this is what I meant by the
way of straddling the boundary between
two unit extension one a changes things
should notice right to your students
we've seen this graphic we've graphed it
so you can make this argument that is
extension one since you have another
tool is not if you want you can say that
tan of theta by 180 degrees is equal to
is our other approach ten something -
and something else do that Bob what is
the equation look like what's going to
go in here yeah and and then what's on
our Dom down one plus now you might be
really good at this thing to just say
it'll be head but I convened the supply
to graph for you tell me what can
hundred eighty degrees look at it there
it is right there right so this is tan
beta minus zero on what one plus zero
which survives rules surprise surprise
is Kathy okay so either these techniques
will get you to the same place but
they're just gone about in this slightly
different way this is a long way around
for one to a button
it's the ones